I'm gonna try to get them off the floor
Ritz toasted chips has brought us
together to talk about the most
wonderful time of year March Madness so
Carlos what is your favorite March
Madness memory I mean when we want it
duh no I mean obviously 2001 when we got
a chance to win a championship that's
like the best moment man we got to
toasted that toasted that yeah that was
click click that's beautiful how do you
do your bracket there's always multiple
brackets you know I'll have a bracket
where I'm just being analytical I'm
gonna have another bracket where there's
some upsets any game could be an upset
exactly Mario Chalmers hitting that shot
Kansas and Kansas yeah to beat the rose
in Memphis Carmelo as a freshman going
through the tournament winning at
Syracuse as a freshman there's so many
it's like Cinderella stories that happen
all the all the moments that make March
Madness March Madness I do know what
snacks I'm picking yeah for when I'm
watching the game because these are
amazing I'm taking this bowl with me
hahaha
man these are good